ragazzi non so se vi ricordate raft quel
gioco li figo dove devi sopravvivere in
mezzo all'oceano ecco è uscito completo
e adesso c'è un bambino a piedi nudi che
ti fissa nel menu ok per esiti ragazzi
venuti questo nuovo io sono felice oggi
siamo tornati su raft che è uscito
finalmente nuovo mondo lesbo ace anche
alla difficoltà nome del mondovì che
mondo parli che è una zattera in mezzo
all'oceano non lo so qua non prende in
tempo non prende l'inter crea montelepre
difficoltà normale da una figata assurda
qualcuno mi spiega non mi ricordo
salve acsi lancio la roba che ha già è
vero che le provviste le prende di così
io prendo le provviste lanciando
l'uncino e trascinante chiaro e molto
chiare bello mi piace il fatto che non
mi ricordo ai barili che contengono
tanta roba
certo questo non ricordi barili facciamo
un sacco di roba tutti insieme perfetto
mamma mia che mi grassi aveva patate
asse il chief no no ti faccio mio dio
forse sono solo corri corri c'è ma nel
mio fatto ma c'è un'isola ma l'avete
perché voi mi sembra che la guardo mi
sembra che si stia avvicinando o brutto
pezzente è che l'h aiuto non so come si
si non sono armi con armi e va al cuore
di pesca
mamma mia che brutta roba potrebbe
essere un problema ma si sta avvicinando
non solo io ho trovato sicura mica posso
raccogliere l'isola no però vabbè
io voglio andarci sopra posso salire
possa egli a chiamarle tua sorella morta
ce l'ho fatta ma a raccogliere blu
accesso degli oggetti finissimo dove io
vedo che c'è qualcosa la giura che devo
andare a controllare squalo permettendo
vai trovo però ci vado la sentono sento
che trovate una zattera il tutto il
casino e sto ancora raccogliendo
materiali non ho fatto ancora niente già
trovato di tutto
raccogli cassa lui lavato frequenta roma
ce l'ha o l'ha fondata aiuto ma sa
fondata perché ok va bene ok c'è una
roba che prima di fare il depuratore
dell'acqua perché devo mangiare bere che
c'è una norma che voglio capire ma la
vela 10 d'ora 10 vs 20 di foglie e tre
di rottami voglio vedere com'è fatta la
vela bella crea tieni premuto r per una
rotazione fluida non il brevetto da
navigatore quindi non so bene se stava
ma funziona però proviamoci sea of
thieves assisi funziona che figata
ma che storia si può pure se te li
mortacci quanto difficile sopravvivere
ok laboratorio è semplice mai hanno
creato vai vai vai veloce bianche
schiatto classe se the river e 72 fare
il bicchiere di morti tashi mia stanza
vuota crea le plastiche rai e riempi con
acqua salata
metti la terza salata pai ha più dato
baby acqua salata
ai depurato che sto schiattando nepi con
acqua dolce o bevi o mio dio riuscita a
salvarmi per niente allora vediamo se
riesco a fare robe decenti che hanno la
pesca è ancora non ce l'ho però ho
abbastanza corda quindi crea accordo
chiama la pesca crea o come vede
intanto pesco vediamo se funziona beh
ottimo vi prego abboccate perché se no
non so come magna ne prego
fu una trota mangia e non posso cuocerla
la griglia che o c'è una zattera andiamo
a vedere nel frattempo stai per madonna
ti ammazzo che 10 ti spacco la testa già
se ti spacco quanto ti mangiano una idea
veramente devi stare fermo ti distruggo
la famiglia continuare a travasare i
trequarti e va capito alla griglia c'è
veramente poco spazio susta zattera però
sto facendo il minimo indispensabile
ragazzi scusatemi perché c'è veramente
troppe cose da fare ti fai magna ancora
né cotto il pesce occhio rai approaching
è proprio perfetto ma dovrebbe andar giù
da sola vai a mangiare o arringa cotta
magna perfetto su creare un ricevitore
delle cose per mandare dei segnali
d'aiuto ma vi pare utile per localizzare
i segnali radio vicini pretino vai lo
mettiamo
mettiamo qui quindi ora come ora non
sono messo male anche se ci ho messo un
botto di arrivare così l'inizio è
difficilissima e che ho fatto un voto di
roba il tavolo per creare altre cose lo
squalo che mi portasse i trequarti e la
griglia per cucinare il cibo quindi ho
un botto di roma vorrebbe andare avanti
perfetto tra l'altro tav era quello che
mi serviva vai chiodo posso fare un
altro lato retino non mi piace faccio
una trentina sono a posto
ciao ciao poveri
ciao poveri due lettini vigna e
incredibile quanta roba troppo in un
video solo l'aiuto spetta a girare
averla girare la testa il cosa la
casacca vai vai vai già facciamo la
facciamo a prendere al barile si
perfetto quanta roba che non solo
episodio ok barbabietola cruda che
schifo lavora va via uno qua
ai lati e 1t proclama perfetto più
retini faccio ragazzi più è facile
farmar e materiali e più possono
velocemente costruirmi lacca la zattera
più grande e cercare i rinforzi perché
alla fine è questo che si di questo
anche si tratta per costruire un
eventuale antenna che può aiutarmi
quell'isola non riesco a scalarla perché
è troppo alta mi devo fare le scale
perché puoi fare le scale ovviamente
porca eva mi sa che tu stai fermo stai
fermo hai rotto il trequarti di cabasisi
non puoi riparare allora vaffan cuore
c'è della roba lassù e vedere se riesco
a scavare stava direttissima isola in
qualche modo non so come ci serve una
scala lega come faccio a fare le scale
porca eva proposta tattica andiamo verso
il barile se il bari la un rottame mi
facci chiodi se riesco a farmi chiodi
alla scala se alla scala salgo sul viso
ne prendo le robe solo che non so
ti prego prontamente prego ti prego ti
prego ti prego si va da una mattina
aveva anche culo perfetto l'effetto
perfetto ora torno a tutti indietro
bene così vai vai perfetto no si può
benissimo che che amore bene soffia
vento soffia veloce la pagaia eccola qui
sbuffare by paga chiamo non so come si
faccia anche è perfetto ma quanto lento
no no no no no no no no no no no no
oppure la scala la scala tua madre
la scala stavo ben tre zone
non è vero io ve lo giuro non ci voglio
credere nasca il retino dio
la scala la scala erre to2
tu hai uno l'unico quadrato di tutta la
barca che era impeccabile era quello
porca eva l'unico non ci voglio credere
allucinante non ci arriverò mai beh ci
arriverò mai avevo la scala posta ma
niente distrutta
ogni volta che costruisco qualcosa sto
squalo di me ma riguarda non riuscirà il
family friendly non ci arrivo più cioè
capito come ha distrutto l'unica roba
che potevo fare forse saltando cioè
fatta che culo ferma ferma terna che va
a muoviamoci piano che l'ha fatta la se
ne vada sì ma è la madonna quanto a roma
sì però stai ferma zattera c'è qualcosa
fa sopra lo vedo ma non riesco a
raggiungerlo avere una scala maledizione
vabbè adesso ragazzi concludo qua appena
avrò la barca la zattera un po più
grossa posso farmi l'occorrente per
tentare di chiamare i soccorsi perché
puoi chiamare i soccorsi a quanto ho
capito che i ragazzi spero vi sia
piaciuto come si è visto quanto mi piace
anche avrei stato cambiato notizia se un
sacco rischiate noi ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]